aujourd'hui je suis juste un appel ce
matin meilleur 7 3 puis la journée
d'avant sait trop si les messages
enregistrés mais comme qui me semble
être ce mandarin des appels ou en
parlant mandarin fabriquent souvent mais
j'ai des collègues qui m'ont dit que les
appelle comme ça mais j'en ai toujours
de temps en temps mais je les blocs
est-ce que vous en recevez vous des
appels à répétition sur votre téléphone
intelligent ce type de fraude qui semble
prendre de l'ampleur
et on le sait les fraudeurs ont beaucoup
d'imagination donc raffine également
leurs stratagèmes et le centre
antifraude du canada qui a fait une mise
en garde concernant de nouvelles
tendances de fraudeurs ceux qui se font
passer pour des employés d'organismes
gouvernementaux par exemple ou qui
prétendent être des policiers
on en parle ce matin de ces fraudes
téléphonique avec sylvain paquette du
bureau canadien du crédit ce paquet
bonjour bonjour vous voyez vraiment une
augmentation dans le phénomène de ce
type de fraude l'aller les appels
téléphoniques
j'ai vraiment nouveau recul de sens
puisque les fraudeurs savent que les
gens ici ont été victimes de vol de
données au québec dont qui ont utilisé
des stratagèmes qui vise par exemple mes
relations sociales ou vous rapport des
impôts ou des renseignements personnels
susceptibles de pouvoir les intéressés
pour aller chercher d'autres
informations vous concernant
donc ils nous appellent pour obtenir ces
informations c'est ça et ce sont des
appels qui proviennent d'outre-mer là on
voit des fois des numéros de téléphone
avec des codes régionaux qu'on connaît
pas du tout son attrait paraît en ce
moment la vague course et de ce sont des
appels provenant de supposément justice
canada pour vous dire que votre nos
relations sociales a été compromis et il
vous demande d'appui sur leur évidemment
si vous appuyez sur leur vote rappelle
vont être transférés sur une autre ligne
ils nous on a fait quelques expériences
et on s'est aperçu que c'était une ligne
payante à 1000 euros la minute seront
donc si on fait le contraire comment
évidemment si vous êtes transférer un
agent ils vont vous mettre en attente et
vous allez devoir payer 1000 $ hureaux
alors
évidemment on sait pas encore si sa
cible le consommateur directement ou les
entreprises ou compagnies de téléphone
et on sait pas vraiment d'où ils
viennent ces appels quelle est l'origine
évidemment utilisent des cols régional
de l'ontario du québec d'autres pays
aussi donc on ici on rappelle le numéro
on voit que le mérou n'est pas en
service
donc on peut pas identifier la
provenance est ce qu'on doit faire donc
si ça sonne son téléphone puis qu'on
reconnaît pas numéro évidemment ne pas
répondre si possible sinon si vous
répondez il vous entendez le message
raccroche immédiatement le signal ihu
près de 200 ans d'histoire du canada
si vous avez été victime mais vous avez
appuyé sur leur par exemple vous avez
parlé à un agent peut-être à ce moment
le signifier à votre poste de police de
quartier ou moins pour rédiger un
rapport que le ghana sont les compagnies
téléphone rembourse pour ces frais là
qui sont engendre automatiquement
généralement oui mais toutefois si vous
avez fait l'appel après difficile donc
vous allez avoir à vous battre contre
votre compagnie thé de femmes oui oui et
de là vous vous menez sur votre page
facebook actuellement une enquête et
vous demandez aux gens d'aller remplir d
répondre aux questions pour essayer de
faire des croisements essaie d'en savoir
davantage sur ces fraudeurs oui enfin on
a créé un sondage qui permet de à savoir
si les fraudeurs ont obtenu le numéro de
téléphone via du balayage sur internet
où il s'il s'agit d'une fuite de données
d'un organisme par exemple ou une
entreprise québécoise et ça va nous
permettre à travers ce sondage le de
poids peut être ciblé une entreprise qui
seraient victimes de vols de données de
pouvoir les avertir et transmettre
l'information aux autorités
il y en a tellement de la fraude c'est
incroyable couvrir les crimes de la
est-ce que c'est suffisamment récré mais
à votre avis par notre code criminel au
canada les types de fraudes
malheureusement les autorités n'ont pas
non pas les effectifs pour enquêter là
dessus
donc nous on présente le 26 novembre
prochain lors d'un événement on appelle
sur le groupe fraude basters ce sont des
groupes de discussion sur la fraude et
on va présenter un projet pour signer
une pétition en fait pour demander au
gouvernement d'abroger le code criminel
est de rendre les fraudeurs responsable
est obligé de rembourser les victimes
mais s'ils sont pas en mesure de
rembourser devons avoir des peines
d'emprisonnement plus long c'est pas le
cas présentement dont donc fraudeurs qui
se fait arrêter n'est pas tenue de
rembourser une certaine somme par
exemple s'il est reconnu coupable
non ça dépend de en fait ça va dépendre
du juge de ce qui va être attribués
comme ca attendu donc vous lancer ce
mouvement là le 26 novembre prochain
en attendant paris voir sur votre site
internet pour remplir le sondage
bien sûr il ya la mise en garde
également et dont je parlais du centre
antifraude du canada qui rappelle là
qu'il ya vraiment une recrudescence dans
ce type de fraude lent et ce soir au
téléjournal on vous présente un
reportage complet sur réussir des séries
si telle est ce un paquet merci merci
une fois ce matin